the FTC is right to investigate whether
the purchase of Subway by the same firm
that owns Jimmy John's and McAllister's
Deli creates a sandwich shop
Monopoly Senator Elizabeth Warren is
worried about America's sandwich shop
Monopoly this tweet reads like satire
but it's not and the replies were
hilarious from people joking about the
foot long industrial complex to asking
if it's a parody account and it
obviously made for great meeme poter but
while Senator Warren might be a ham her
tweet is no laughing matter Federal anti
power is supposed to promote competition
and prevent price gouging but
politicians like Warren use it against
big corporations they dislike is the
sandwich industry too concentrated of
course not there are countless options
from Panera and Blimpy to witch witch
and Jersey miks or you can make your own
sandwich at home Americans don't need
protection from a supposed sandwich shop
Monopoly we need lower taxes and Freer
markets to incentivize business growth
and give consumers more options whether
it's a sandwich or something that
actually impacts their daily life